shifting you're shifting to the future
i'm talking about yes that's my job
well well well okay and we're talking
about the future
and and you can easily and that's that's
um and i'm saying we should
look in to the last 40 years as clues
for the future yes it's it takes
we've had 40 years of stagnation where
wages are stagnant
the most likely people are wealthier
there's fewer deaths drug addiction is
lower
right there's all sorts of reasons why
excuse me eric peter is peter's making
the point that and as a general
we don't agree on a basic fact no no i
know this clip is from a 2012 debate
between eric schmidt and peter thiel
and as you can see they are getting
nowhere with each other the debate went
on for 40 minutes
but they were never able to align on
whether or not america is in a period of
stagnation
so i want to try and talk about the key
points here and try and see who looks
right in hindsight
as a bit of background peter thiel was
the co-founder of paypal and palantir
and now runs the venture capital firm
founder's fund eric schmidt was the ceo
and later the executive chairman of
google
they're both intellectual heavyweights
in silicon valley and while they agree
that computer technology has been
advancing rapidly
they disagree on whether or not america
has been seeing rapid growth more
broadly
their debate is interesting not only
because schmidt is a prominent
democratic donor
and teal was a trump backer in 2016 so
they clearly have very different policy
prescriptions
but they disagree on a very fundamental
level as to what is currently happening
in america
thiel has been very vocal about the idea
that american progress has been stagnant
since the 1970s and he summarizes it
well in this clip
i sort of date the this era of stagnate
relative stagnation and slowed progress
all the way back to the 1970s so i think
it's been
close to half a century that we've been
in this um in this era of um
of seriously slowed uh slowed progress
um obviously a very big exception to
this has been the world of bits
um computers internet mobile internet
software
um and so silicon valley has somehow
been this uh been this dramatic
exception you know it uh
um and whereas the world of atoms has
been uh has been much slower for
for something like 50 years and thiel
himself admits that it can be difficult
to precisely quantify the pace of
innovation and its effect on the broader
economy
he tends to focus on three areas of
stagnation in particular
the first is the speed of travel he
cites the fact that the concorde was
shut down in 2003
and the true speed of air transportation
has been dropping ever since due to
increased airport security
the second is in healthcare where costs
have been increasing
well ahead of inflation for decades with
only moderate increases to life
expectancy and health outcomes to show
for it
he often points to the war on cancer
that president nixon declared in 1971
and has yet to see any promising
developments
lastly he focuses a lot of attention on
education
similar to healthcare education costs
have risen significantly above inflation
while median real wages have stagnated
his focus on median real wage growth is
fascinating to me because it's one of
the most
unexplained phenomena in present day
america and it has an immense impact on
everyday life
as opposed to a future where we all work
less and are still better off each year
he draws a comparison to the red queen's
race in alice in wonderland
in this futile race everyone must run
faster and faster to stay in the same
place
these are interesting points because
while teal often describes himself as a
libertarian
many left-leaning political commentators
agree with him that these are underlying
problems that need to be addressed they
just disagree on how best to remedy
these issues
teal points to two key areas that could
be possible solutions to the problem of
american stagnation
the first is government regulation as a
libertarian
he believes that regulation by the fda
has led to stagnation and drug
development
local nimby movements have halted
progress in transportation
and fear of nuclear disasters has
stopped the development of alternative
energy
here's teal speaking about regulation in
more detail one cut on this is always to
differentiate the world of atoms and
bits and that uh
since the 1970s we've had a narrow cone
of progress around
atoms they've been those are around bits
like you know computers
internet mobile internet software these
have been advancing fairly quickly
the world of atoms somewhat more slowly
you know when i was an undergraduate at
uh
at stanford um i was in the late 80s
i would say that almost every
engineering field in retrospect was a
bad field to go into it was already
obvious you shouldn't go into nuclear
engineering
aeroastro engineering weren't that good
but even all these other fields
were not going to do that well in the
decades ahead because we were no
electrical engineering was still okay
computer science was the really good
field to go into
in the late 80s all the other
engineering fields it was just regulated
to death
there wasn't that much you could do in
the world of atoms and uh
it turned out that we had you know a lot
of uh a lot of a slowed
process progress and i i think that if
we sort of analyze this question of the
uh
the rate of scientific progress
politically and think of it as um
as sort of um university professors or
entrepreneurs or venture capitalists um
exaggerating about how much good they're
doing and how great they are
we understand that the incentives are
always to exaggerate and to uh
to say that you know we're we're just
around the corner from curing cancer
around the corner in all these different
things and yet uh
it's been uh it's been in some
significant ways slower over the last uh
last 40 or 50 years looking back on
these points in 2020
helps us understand how intractable some
of these problems really are
while he supported trump in 2016 he
pulled support for the 2020 re-election
campaign
which could suggest that he doesn't
think trump will ever be able to achieve
the level of change necessary to spur
innovation
in the world of atoms as he describes it
the second pathway tlcs as a way forward
is to bring about a change in the way
innovators think about the future
he outlines the four ways that societies
generally think about the future in a
2013 talk at south by southwest
most simplistically you can say that the
future
is either optimistic or pessimistic
and it's either determinate or
indeterminate
an optimistic future is one where
you believe things will be better than
the present
on whatever axis defines better
a pessimistic future is one where you
think things will generally be worse
and then a determinate future is one
where you can sort of
map out reasonable amounts of it and and
plan
against it and then an indeterminate one
is uh is where you have absolutely uh no
clue and it's sort of just
a random walk all the way teal generally
believes that americans are currently in
the upper right quadrant
meaning that they are still optimistic
about the future but they don't have a
deterministic vision of how we will get
there
he thinks the best way forward is for
individuals to start thinking
deterministically
and to bring back a clear vision of the
future that was so popular in the mid
20th century he sums this up really well
in a debate with mark andreessen from
2017.
i think we can be doing a lot better you
know we i think we can be looking at a
whole range of technologies
futuristic computer technologies
artificial intelligence
quantum computing space technologies
biotech
next generation life sciences we should
be finding a cure for cancer for
alzheimer's
um and i think it is not a fact of
nature that the slowdown has happened
it's a cultural decision
we've become risk-averse we've been
regulated to death we've become um
incrementalist and we're not willing to
uh really uh take the bold steps we've
talked ourselves into thinking
that uh that uh throwing um throwing
angry birds at pigs
is the best we can do and that's and i
think we can do better
i think his summation of the need to be
more ambitious when it comes to
technological development is quite
powerful
because it runs counter to the common
narrative in silicon valley the
technology is saving the world and
progress is inevitable
it is in some ways scary to accept that
unless we move mountains to bring about
meaningful change
we will stagnate as a country it's much
easier to believe that the future is
ever advancing
and we are already on the right track
but what do you think
let me know your opinion on peter thiel
and his core ideas by leaving a comment
below
and if you enjoyed this video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching